YURI GRINSHTEYN: We covered
using Service-Level Indicators
to measure the reliability
of our services
and using Service
Level Objectives to set
reliability targets
in our first episode.
But what happens when
that service has a problem
and we start burning
error budget?
How can we configure
alerting to let
us know that our users
are unhappy while managing
our operational load?
Today, I'm going to show
you how to calculate and use
error budget burn
rate thresholds
as an optimum approach
to your alerting set up.
Welcome to "Engineering for
Reliability" with Google Cloud.
To help us, let's review
chapter 5 of the "SRE Workbook"
called "Alerting on SLOs."
If you haven't read
it before, no worries.
We'll link to it in the
episode notes below.
The main thing we need to
take away from that chapter
is that the best way to have
sufficiently sensitive alerts,
while at the same time
reducing false positives,
is to use multi-window,
multi burn-rate alerts.
But first, what's a burn rate?
Error budget burn
rate is a measure
of how fast,
relative to your SLO,
your service consumes
error budget.
For example, a service that
has exactly zero error budget
left at the end of the
SLO evaluation period
has a burn rate of 1.
A service that consumes
all of its error budget
halfway through the
SLO evaluation period
has a burn rate of 2 and so on.
We calculate our burn rate by
looking at three main inputs--
the SLO and its
evaluation period,
the amount of error
budget consumed or burned,
and the window over
which that burn happens.
That's our alerting window.
Let's walk through
a specific example.
Let's say our service
has an availability
SLO of 95% over a
rolling 28-day window.
We want to know if we're
having a problem that's
impacting end users.
A great place to
start is to create
an alert that lets us know that
we've consumed 2% of our error
budget in the last hour.
We use this equation to
calculate the burn rate
threshold for our
alert, which is 13.44.
We also want to
know if we're seeing
a slower burn rate, too, 5%
of error budget in six hours.
This time, our burn
rate threshold is 5.6.
We want our alert
to notify us only
when we're still actively
burning error budget to reduce
the number of false positives.
To do this, we'll create both
of our alerts with two windows--
a long window and
a short window.
A good starting place is to
make the long window 12 times
as long as the short window.
By using multi window alerts,
we keep our detection time low
and minimize our reset
time so that the alert
doesn't keep firing once the
incident has been mitigated.
OK, that was a lot.
The main thing to
remember at this point
is that we can use error budget
burn rate alerts to detect
issues with our service long
before our SLO is actually
threatened.
Now, let's have a look
at how to set them up
in Cloud Operations.
Start at the Dashboard page.
Select Monitoring from
the Products menu,
and click on Services.
Here's a service with an
availability SLO defined
but no alerts configured.
The SLO is evaluated over
a rolling 28-day window.
In order to create an error
budget burn alert for the SLO,
you need to specify two things.
The first one is the
look-back duration
or the window over
which the error
budget burn rate is evaluated.
The second entry is
the burn-rate threshold
or the value of
the burn rate that
must be true over the look-back
back window for the alert
to fire.
To configure a fast error
budget burn rate alert
that will fire if
2% of error budget
is burned over an hour, set
the look-back duration to 60
minutes and the burn
rate threshold to 13.44.
For a slow burn alert that
will fire if 5% of error budget
is burned over six hours,
set the look-back duration
to 360 minutes and
the burn rate to 6.
Name your loading policy,
specify your notification
settings for the alert,
provide any documentation
or additional
information that should
be delivered with the alert,
and save the alert policy.
Finally, confirm that the
alert has been created.
Now, if the availability
of the service degrades,
the alert will fire, and an
incident will be created.
We've configured an alert
based on error budget
burn rate threshold, but
what happens when it fires?
Let's have a look.
Let's see what happens
when an error budget burn
rate threshold alert fires.
From the Services
Overview page, we
can see that we have a service
with an SOL alert firing.
We can show just those
services with firing alerts.
We can go to Service
Details to confirm
that we have an unhealthy
SLO with a firing alert.
We can expand the SLO
to confirm that we're
seeing a degradation in our
service level indicator.
On the Error Budget
tab, we can confirm
that we're starting to see
additional error budget burn.
Further down, we can see
the logs being generated
by the logs for our service.
In this case, we're seeing an
increased number of 500 server
error logs confirming that
our service is currently
having an issue.
Thanks for joining me today.
We covered a lot.
You learned about why
alerting on error budget
burn is a great way
to balance keeping
users happy against
operational overload.
We then figured out how to
calculate error budget burn
rates and so how to
use them to set up
alerting for your services
in Cloud Operations.
Thanks so much for watching.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more "Engineering for
Reliability" with Google Cloud.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]